Matthew?
>> Yes?
>> I have a surprise for you.
>> Oh what'd you get me?
>> My genome.
>> Oh you got your genome's information back. What do you think?
>> I love it. It's really exciting. I found out a lot
about my traits. Including some diseases that I'm not a carrier for.
>> Great.
>> Which is great news. As well as my risk factor for some complex traits.
>> Well, it's kind of like a big storybook of you, isn't it?
>> It is, except that there's something missing that I
kind of wanted to know about.
>> What's that?
>> I wanted to know, like, where I fit in in the grand scheme of things.
>> Well, Lauren, when, when two people love each other very much.
>> Okay, Matt, Matt, I know where I came from in that way.
>> Oh.
>> I've had that talk before.
>> Right.
>> I'm talking about, like, 10000 years of ancestry.
I want to know where I came from like that.
>> Well, it is true. Your genome can really reveal that information
giving you close family members even answers into your deep distant past.
All you need to know, is where to look. What? Where are we?
>> Yeah, this is the genome library. And all of these
books represent the genomes of thousands of people all across the world.
>> Wow!
>> And using this information we can make comparisons and,
possibly find family relationships that you never even knew about before.
>> Well, I mean, I know I have a brother,
and I have half-brother, I have parents, I know those things.
>> Well sure, you know these relationships.
But your genome has a lot of secrets to
it, and it could possibly reveal that some of
the relationships you think are true may not be
as true as you think. And it could reveal
new relationships you never even knew about before. And
don't forget, there are adopted individuals who never even
had an opportunity to know who their blood relatives
are, so this could be a great opportunity for them.
>> Well they're really fortunate to have this
school, I think this is an awesome opportunity for
anybody. But, I am still interested in knowing
where I fit in the grand scheme of things.
Well, you're in luck, Lauren, because with this genomic
information, we can get pretty far in answering that question.